what's up you beautiful souls welcome to
another episode of get close i am your
co-host gio and i'm bart
and um
do you believe in uh the love language
like categories
like like uh words of affirmation
physical touch
acts of service
quality time damn i'm a love master i
know all of them
do i believe in them yeah
like do you believe there's that like
i'm the one thing
or
because when i after i read it
i was like i don't know i don't i think
i was like i think it works for guys but
i think for chicks is all chicks for all
of them and i don't care how much they
[ __ ] lie and [ __ ] i think all
guys are all of them too i think all
people are all of them
i think guys are predominantly they got
one big one and the other ones are like
i think girls are like
theirs are way closer across the board
i don't know so for because i talk to
any chick right and you go like this why
are you talking to chicks because i love
them
but like let's say i'm like
hey
just so you know
i'm going to put all the food on the
table
right
get you the cart you want
beautiful house
everything to be covered
i'm never
going to compliment you ever again
girls of blood oh my god my world's
gonna end if you tell a dude hey
every day you get a [ __ ]
and i'm gonna be really nice to you i
don't know we live in a different
generation and if you go but i'll never
compliment you dudes are like i don't
care if somebody
i don't think that flies anymore
we talk about i don't know the this
generation of males now like everyone's
in tune with their emotions and i'm not
presenting this in a negative light in
any way my emotions are between my legs
yeah and so is your [ __ ] brain
because you're [ __ ] dumb
why is it so big down there then
is it
your hole is pretty gaping
there's a lot of iq in that hole no
there's not
um i don't know i don't know i i don't
know if like generalizing anything is
ever good well not generalizing but like
you know how they people did like
there's that whole thing of like some
people are this some people know this
something with this yeah i don't agree
with any of that
even with like zodiac signs right like
how many years was i like
this is [ __ ] i'm not gonna buy into
this [ __ ] because no one like they're
generalizing this group of people right
and i'm like i'm not gonna buy into that
[ __ ] because
no it's not true
and then they come out with like the
moon sign and the sun size
sign i recently heard an explanation
that makes me go
oh
yeah i heard the same one but go ahead
which one's yours go no you say it first
just say it don't worry the sound
doesn't sound
where did you hear yours say it no you
say yours go go rock paper scissors okay
yeah [ __ ] off okay fine
so mine is um
we'll go through a series of yes or no
questions right
uh
is your brain development
affected by gravity see that's the same
thing that i was going to say go ahead
and you say the whole thing go no no go
i won you son of a [ __ ] then stop
trying to pretend like you're smart and
take my thunder no i'm not we were in
the same car when it was explained
really yes
go i didn't remember i heard it from but
this is in here
but
is brain affected by gravity yes
okay
so if you know that then you also know
that during different months there's
different tides and different
gravitational pulls on the earth yes or
no yes okay
so then because of that and it's a 12
month cycle under cycles then
wouldn't there mean that there's
similar gravitational pulls
on certain months
depending on the births yes exactly so
because of that because of we do have
these cycles and there's these certain
gravitational pulls on the earth as it
as your brain is developing
then it's pulling on your brain in a way
where every single month kind of have a
certain
uh characteristic or category of traits
and personalities
and that's why that's that would be the
closest to a scientific explanation of
how horoscopes work yeah um but what i
was trying to get at is the reason why
and that's the same thing i heard um it
was one of our friend's dad because we
did talk about that and we did go down
the [ __ ] path of like yeah but it's a
generalization and you know you really
can't be on that stuff and then he so
eloquently came into the conversation
very calm
and with his deep voice and was like
explaining that and we were all like huh
but my point i was trying to make is the
reason why i don't like it is because
people use these things as crutches and
sometimes they're like i'm late because
i'm a taurus and i'm like nah you're
late because you just suck at time
management yeah you know the same thing
with um i don't like crutches for
anything
exactly same thing um so the same thing
with love languages yes i do feel like
um there is some truth to that and i do
love the idea of people now exploring
what are the things that they enjoy and
why they enjoy them right like how does
their brain work how does their emotions
work like i love when people are
exploring themselves so that they can
live a happier life and they can be of
service to others and make other people
happy right
um
so uh to that i'm like cool i love that
but i don't think it just stops there so
when you do make this [ __ ] joke and i
know you're joking of like but women are
everything we are all everything
you know like guys are everything too
yes some things will have more like if
they're all buckets some buckets will
have will need to be filled more than
others i really don't care about words
of affirmation
yes you do
i really don't you [ __ ] do but your
words of affirmation are different when
you go hey dad is this is it is the food
good
that's a word of affirmation you dumbass
that's not words of affirmation it's a
it's a variation of it
no that's not words of affirmation at
all it is because you're tied to that
thing no i'm trying to help him find the
truth i didn't even make it i'm just
like hey do you like this no if he likes
it then i'll get him more of it if he
doesn't then we won't do that again
that felt like it escalated really fast
but
trust me there's no that's not worth the
affirmation at all i don't think you
understand what that means okay then
what's words of affirmation words of
affirmation it's like oh you're so
beautiful
no it's my no it's what you receive from
that right so it's it's a version of
them telling you that you did a good job
or that whatever decisions you're making
are good ones no by the way you're
worthy or that you're whatever i'm just
taking them to places do you like this
place and he goes no
okay then why don't you joke around
every time i go why do you have to ask
if you know what he's going to say
because it's so rare and that since he
just moved here i want to find his like
repeatables like oh
because we always joke around and i'm
like daddy issues and you're like yeah i
just want him to love me so i'm like oh
okay i get it because we're joking
around i don't give a [ __ ]
i really was very confusing though i
really don't care about words of
affirmation really yeah so but you
always tell me that you're always like
to do a good job when you're trying to
be cute i'm just being cuny with you but
i really don't give a [ __ ] what you have
what do you say
good for you
then why do you ask that then that's
such a waste of interaction because i'm
being cute with you but i don't even
think it's cute well then i won't say it
anymore
but what makes you think it's cute
because it makes me okay because
can i speak honestly of course i'ma
speak frankly and honestly okay when do
you ever not
i want to mess around with you
then i'm just saying [ __ ] just to
have fun
okay um
i think i'm so secure with myself
that i know where i stand on things that
i don't give a [ __ ] what anyone else has
to say about me
yeah because if good for you that was a
[ __ ] test cause if you don't see
things the way i see it
you're tripping
right to a certain extent right because
you don't you sound [ __ ] rigid so
because of that because of that i'm
i'm uh making myself more vulnerable in
a smaller place just so i can be cute
and have fun with you so you could be
down with us [ __ ] peasants and you
know what we feel with you i could be a
little spoon with you but i don't like a
little spoon i've told you already then
i'm not gonna ask you [ __ ] ever again
here [ __ ] we're going here tonight to
eat yeah exactly
um
yeah because i've never asked for that
like i don't want that what are you
giving it to me for is that what you
just think i wanted what
i'm gonna do a good job well you always
want me to be vulnerable so i know i'll
be vulnerable i see
i see i see yeah so then what is
ultimately okay playing and having a
good time with you that's that's all i'm
ultimately doing but only you know that
because i don't know that i know that
like it's so i i can only perceive
things in my own way right so
the way at least i've operated or i've
seen other people operate is when there
is an insecurity there then you do try
to mask it with other things whether
that's a joke or trying to be cute or
vulnerable or whatever right like we're
constantly masking things so when you
ask that in that fashion i'm like oh
[ __ ] that might be like a sensitive
point for him so let me play along with
that you even acting all cutesy and like
a little baby and stuff that to me is
also another thing that i'm going oh
okay there's something behind that like
did he not receive another [ __ ] lead
wall
that's what's behind it
i won't do it anymore
you know me
i'm so secure with myself i don't give a
[ __ ] i do know that about you yeah you
don't give a [ __ ] like so like let's say
i created something right i think it's
[ __ ] dope i don't need anyone to tell
me that it's dope i don't i'm like this
is dope and if you don't know that it's
dope you are tripping yeah
uh there's this shirt going around um
that i kind of want to buy because it's
just so funny but it's born on a gram
and it looks like it was edited
afterwards but it's like a little
picture right um and it's saying like uh
uh so i hear you don't want to be my
friend uh you should probably get tested
for covet because one of the first side
effect is losing your taste your sense
of taste oh that's funny yeah and i was
like
[Music]
yeah because for me i'm and i'm not
talking about
i'm so secure at
my [ __ ] that's good and bad you know
what i mean like i'm not dope at
everything there's a ton of [ __ ] that i
suck at yeah so the thing
so the [ __ ] that i suck at like a lot i
don't need people to [ __ ] tell me oh
you could do better or whatever
i'm so secure that i'm like i know i
[ __ ] suck
just like like how i feel about the
things i suck at
is the same i feel about the things that
i'm good at no one has to say [ __ ] to me
it is crystal clear where i'm at with
this thing
and if i suck you think i'm good you're
still tripping if i'm dope and you think
i suck you're tripping still too
yeah okay i get that yeah so that's why
because of that words of affirmation
does nothing for me
yeah
what are the other ones what about
probably even to this point i'll show
you how crazy it is
let's say i start doing stand-up again
right
i do a 30-minute set
i come off off stage
dave chappelle's like
like that
my heart immediately goes into two
one heart goes i know [ __ ]
the other one goes oh my god my
childhood hero thought it was dope but
that's how that's that's how secure it
is you know like this side
isn't even about
it's not even about the affirming of my
skill or the affirming about my action
it's just that he saw me that's that's
that i'm in his line of sight that's
that's it
like that's the notice me senpai like
that's that it has nothing to do with
affirmation it's that
the words of affirmation part is like no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you just saw that now
like that
so then okay let me ask you a question
then
so what makes you ask that like did it
do a good job because it's so specific
i'm just being cute with you that's it i
know but it's so specific like what do
you
cause we ask
we
or maybe we don't but
we do things to
um elicit a reaction right i don't know
what the reaction i'm just being cute
with you
oh it's like you know when we have we've
had two german shepherds now
two aggressive ones
right yeah three in total two aggressive
ones
outwardly
right i'll flex chest and everything and
you go come here
the ears goes down and then like there's
like we know why they're doing his butt
wiggles and he comes off and it comes
all small it's not cuteness it's not
trying to be cute we think it's cute but
they're not trying to be cute they just
know who the alpha is
no i think it's going to be cute no of
course he's not trying to be cute well
that's me being cute
and i see it as cute when i see tyson or
meatloaf coming to me like that of
course it's cute
i think it's cute but they're not going
it's time to be cute they're just going
it's time to be submissive because
that's the [ __ ] top dog that's the
boss but i don't even i don't even have
to go hey you don't have to come here me
loaf
okay
interesting way to um just be cute
though okay then maybe i read way too
much into it for sure so then okay
another question
i always learned so much about you on
this [ __ ] like i feel like i'm like
bart for sure i know everything about
him and then you see [ __ ] like chappelle
no [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not normal
that's why
you're not normal
um what are you looking at oh is that
you just you thinking yeah i'm just
thinking isn't that interesting that we
look away when we're thinking
because i was thinking about like
i remember yeah even when i was like in
second grade and i would like get 100 on
a test or something
and she was like good job i'm like i
know
[Laughter]
so i i don't even be in my mind i'm like
that's all you recognized i'm like you
didn't even recognize that not only did
i get 100. i was the first one to turn
it into
i'm like it's not just accuracy
headphones is [ __ ]
it's not just accuracy it's also speed
oh my god
uh i have a little bit of that but i'm
still very humble i'm humble too i don't
say [ __ ] i go oh thank you that's what i
say but my inner thoughts you [ __ ]
fake [ __ ] yeah my inner thoughts
rude
just kidding no it is a sense of
security okay all this name calling is
[ __ ] same 15 if i got 50 like a f right
they go
what is this
in my mind i'm like [ __ ] i [ __ ] know
dude i [ __ ] up should have studied
what the [ __ ] is this is completely
unacceptable right or if the teacher's
like you know what
you could try it better next time like i
could have tried better this time don't
[ __ ] try to make me feel better
[ __ ]
you know that's how i feel
fine
let me ask you a question
so then what is
okay before i ask that one um
why do you feel like
because you're secure with yourself and
this might
not even be the best question to ask i
just don't know what else
but
um
what to you then
does a relationship mean a romantic
relationship
what do you mean
um
so a lot of people right
they they look to romantic partners
because they need them to complete them
right like i just need this person to
complete me
or
um i just don't want to be alone there's
so many reasons why people get in a
relationship and those tend to be like
the popular ones right or because i have
to or
i don't know i just want to be with this
person or i don't know it always feels
like there's there's this thing that's
missing that they're trying to
fill
right or they're just trying to keep up
with the joneses and it's like well
that's what i'm supposed to do i'm
supposed to get married or whatever or
i'm supposed to be in a relationship
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by manscaped
do you guys know
the benefits
of being clean shaven
and bushless
so no [ __ ] right i literally just
got back into vegas today and when i was
traveling i forgot to bring my manscape
trimmer and i've been gone for like two
weeks and my bush goes bananas it starts
growing like crazy
and i haven't trimmed it in over two
weeks and i got a rough reminder
of what i don't like about it so one i
train my ass off every day two it's
summer right now three it's humid in la
and many other places so i'm sweating my
ass off while i'm working out all this
sweat is just dripping down past my
waistband collecting into my pubes so my
pubes end up staying wet like the whole
day because i go straight to work from
there and then i think over time all
those salts or whatever the heck is
going on down there it gets all itchy it
feels uncomfortable
on top of that
i think i'm dealing with some like pubic
eczema or something and so i have to put
on these creams or else it itches like
crazy and i'm like scratching my nuts in
public which is something i don't want
to do but if you don't if you're not
clean-shaven it's like imagine trying to
put lotion
on your hair to get to your scalp it
just looks like you're styling your
pubes down there so right after this ad
read no [ __ ] i'm gonna go shave my
pubes with the manscape and especially
with the lawnmower 4.0 because it has
advanced skin safe technology it has
ceramic blades
so you get very little nicks
it has a led light which i like so when
you go under the nuts sometimes you can
nick yourself because you can't see
what's going on it has all this dope
technology that makes cutting your pubes
a breeze and i've been using them for i
think
probably since we started getting
sponsored so over five years now so if
you want to have clean nuts go check it
out you get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code get close at manscape.com
make sure you go to massgate.com use the
code get close to get 20 percent off and
be clean-shaven and get all the benefits
of a bush-free yard
um
for you who seems that
or at least from my perception it seems
like you don't need anyone
what's the point of you being in a
relationship
i'm peanut butter [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know what i mean no
i'm complete by myself
peanut butter [ __ ] but with
jelly
now you got fireworks
yeah yeah yeah that's how i see it
that's so dope i don't need nobody to
complete me i'm [ __ ] peanut butter
can we be that for halloween peanut
butter jelly yeah and tyka's a big-ass
loaf of bread in the middle we're on the
outside
like that
i like when you get an idea like oh
i like why don't they make peanut butter
like that but i'm like oh it's a sticky
the whole it's easier to hold the bread
yeah that's how i feel i don't ever i
don't uh view it as like um i need
someone to complete me because i think
if you're not complete yourself you're
gonna get yourself in a bad relationship
yeah because you're putting the
responsibility of
your own hundred percent
on someone else i'm peanut butter
[ __ ]
i love it i love it you know yeah no i
do know because i i never knew that
that's what it was for me because for me
the idea of love was was pitched to me
that way right someone that's going to
rescue you um from like disney movies
you that's you know or the the damsel in
distress and like oh
i love you or you fall in love because
it's like oh you complete me you know
yeah and that's why for me the idea of
love i'm like
that ain't for me bro
because i'm pretty solid by myself yeah
so that's why i was convinced that love
doesn't exist i'm never gonna fall in
love i'm just gonna find someone that
i'm compatible with and will eventually
fall into some type of love because now
we have like loyalty to each other duty
to each other like all that [ __ ] right
um because of the same thing where i'm
like i don't need you
and that's why it was so easy for me to
cut girls out of my life you know the
famous story of like me and studying
with the chick and then she
say it again just for shits and giggles
so yeah back in college um i had a study
partner and um
we were studying together and in the
middle of it i think we really hit it
off like we had like a really good
conversation
and then um i was like hey you want to
go to the beach because i think it was
like summer i was like one of those
summer classes and then she's like yeah
so uh and this is like in the talking
phase like super early like um probably
about to be like dating face so we go to
the beach
and then uh i'm teaching our boogie
board and we had like a really really
good time and then we hung out on the
beach and then we went to go eat or
whatever after right
and then afterwards on my way back i was
like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] got distracted
we were in the middle of studying and i
just said you want to go to the beach
and guess what she said
yes
did we finish the book nope
i'm like you're incomplete [ __ ]
and then so
[Laughter]
so i cut it off you know you have some
really good one-liners today so for me
you're incomplete [ __ ] so for me i've
been looking for that complete person
like i've already i'm like i'm peanut
butter where's my jelly so i'm not
looking for no raw ingredients where
you're still missing strawberries or
some [ __ ] i'm like i need someone that
already comes packaged in a [ __ ]
glass jar you got the strawberries you
got the sugar you got the whatever the
[ __ ] all in there i don't want no i
don't want to be dealing with nobody's
raw ingredients
going oh i just need a peanut butter in
my life because in my ass gonna be so
sticky you're gonna be stuck to me the
whole time and i can't do my own thing
either you know i love that yeah so i
was like i
uh
that's what was so easy like like you
know people make fun of me for it
because then i'll like date a girl for a
week or like i'll go pretty good for
like three months and then just i just
cut them out and i'm like oh and
completely it's so cool that you knew
that so early on though
whereas for me um i saw so much
potential in my partners that i was like
uh not that i'm gonna change them i've
never thought like i've never wanted to
be the girl to change anyone but it was
more like
i know the [ __ ] way to do [ __ ] like i
i have the tenacity to get [ __ ] done i
have my eye on the prize i know where
the [ __ ] i'm going i see your potential
i want us both to hit our potentials
let's go you know and then it got to the
point where i'm like oh god i feel like
i'm i want
you to do better more than you want to
do better
but that was after like [ __ ] a year
two three years and me going
[ __ ] i wish i had that more where i'm
like nah man i'm jelly
i need some raw ass peanut butter
ingredients
cause i think um i wasted so many years
but i'm not gonna call them wasted
because they weren't wasted yeah it's
learning yeah i think um
ironically
one of the
benefits of having divorced parents
was because of that
so like my mom
she raised me right
and seeing such a strong woman operate
like this little
five foot ninety pound asian lady
um raised me starting when i was six
take me to kung fu signed me up for
chinese school um me getting into all
the trouble that i did i would see her
come to the school go to the district
office
like do all of that
and also sell her house when i went up
in value got a new house
see your work work up the ranks she got
you mentor men mailman male mentors
taught me how to surf would have like uh
her co-workers help me with homework and
stuff
like just seeing what is capable out of
a female i think that has always been
like subconsciously i'm like of course
you can't get beneath that yeah i'm like
oh damn like this like she doesn't need
nobody
so that's what i always saw so i think
that's why when i was looking for
partners i'm like if you're a need
somebody [ __ ] then you're not you're
not
what i need you know
get out of here you incomplete [ __ ]
yeah like if you i need someone that
also
don't need nobody yeah and because i i i
had my mom yeah you know so i think that
was like one of the pros isn't that
crazy how like um i love these when i
always say ain't that crazy
i think i'm my biggest fan sometimes
but isn't it crazy like
your mom
shaped who you want to be with and my
mom shaped
uh parts of what i never wanted to be
with
or i never wanted to be like i mean i
think it goes both ways
and i love my mom by the way and she's a
[ __ ] badass i think it goes both ways
so on the same token
that my mom is so independent
and so um
like self-sufficient the other side is
at least from my dad's point of view
she's extremely rigid
because of that and because she's a
rigid
she doesn't know how to be
collaborative because that's what i
try to achieve you know like peanut
butter and jelly
they're self-sustaining but they're
collaborative still
so they come together to make a bigger
thing
and so i think um plus one equals three
yeah so because of that i also saw that
from my mom
um because like my dad would like you
know always remind me growing up she'd
like did you has your mom ever said i'm
sorry for anything and i'm like damn i
don't think she ever has because it's
always only her way
and so that was also something kind of
like your mom where i'm like i never
want to be like that like i like the
these independent strong parts
but i also never want to be someone that
doesn't bend
you're very bendy yeah i want to be able
to when it counts you got to be strong
but you still got to be able to bend you
know yeah got to be like bamboo
is that what you have yeah that's why
that's funny yeah um
interesting i love that
yeah i just learned that about myself
right now i'm like that's probably why i
called it i never believed in love
because i always it was always pitch to
me or at least i would hear it that way
not that they were always saying your
conception of love was like two
incomplete people coming together yeah
and like this person completes you
and now like you you can't live without
this person and stuff because now you're
just lost i do think the person benefits
you
and i think they help you evolve
absolutely i mean they should but i
don't think they should complete you
they should right they should help you
evolve they should push you to be your
best
and i don't want to say push because
that sounds like they're doing a lot of
work but they should definitely be
encouraging yeah um
and and you should always feel like
you're growing with this person and
you're allowed to grow even if they
can't grow cause there's gonna be times
where you know i might be stuck with
some [ __ ] and i'm trying to deal with it
and you're
growing and succeeding and doing stuff
and i might not be i might be at my
worst you know but
um
like it should be okay for you to for me
to still root for you and like be
encouraging and like instead of pulling
you down and being like no i'm miserable
be miserable with me
um
but yeah i never i never really saw it
like that literally until right now that
i'm like
because how many times and i [ __ ] around
a lot and we do speak so crass to each
other because we're just that secure in
our relationship and in ourselves that
we can be like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] or whatever
um and we know that there's no male
intent or like any
any passive aggressiveness attached to
it
that like i will tell you and i do [ __ ]
around with you where i'm like you know
if you were to die only like
okay wait that sounds really [ __ ] up i
don't say it like that but i'm like what
do i really need you for
you know that sounds better
well the other way
but i'm getting at what we're talking
about now yeah right like
don't be as sensitive as [ __ ] when i
say that yeah yeah um
i'm just it's my [ __ ] up dysfunctional
way of saying hey you got with a really
good partner because i can handle my own
[ __ ] yeah you're just saying and i can
handle your [ __ ] jelly yeah you're just
saying jelly yeah yeah exactly how cute
i want to make it some shirts peanut
butter and jelly
well you're the peanut butter i'm the
jelly i love that um
but
yeah damn that like really opened up my
eyes and i love that
how do you think you got that got what
where you're like i'm complete
[ __ ]
just from uh watching my mom operate and
just seeing how like this little chick
in a different country doesn't speak the
language
um
you know the house that my mom lives in
now yeah
like that was a two-bedroom house
and she got the whole thing completely
remodeled didn't look like that she
added an extra bathroom extra like she
didn't do it herself but for someone
that has to like dig through the
classifieds of newspapers to find
contractors find real estate agents like
i remember growing up there's no like uh
h r block whatever like this is an h r
block like a tax people oh like my mom's
like accountant would come over that one
time a year and my mom literally has a
stack of receipts
like that to do taxes he would come over
yeah he would come over and then she's
like highlighting [ __ ] and doing all
that so like just she got him to come
over my mom would have to go to her tax
guy well you know my mom my mom got
[ __ ] construction worker to fix the
ac yes right above her desk yeah so she
worked so just seeing how how she
operated
um made me go wow like people are
actually really capable
so one that's i think subconsciously
what i started looking for so anytime
like we went out with like uh
like you know how like
it's really common for like a guy group
to kind of have like a sister girl group
for some reason like it's just like oh
they're like the go-to group whether
they date or not yeah yeah and uh we
would just go out and do things and then
the ones that are like oh
like that like i just never it was an
immediate turn off
like let's say we're like we're all
walking to set up a bonfire right and
then the ones that like couldn't like
carry a chair or something i was just
like the [ __ ] i mean you can't carry a
[ __ ] chair
it's just like stuff like that you know
yeah some guys love that [ __ ] some guys
love it like oh my little princess yeah
maybe it works for them um but for me i
was like wait what i'm like dude you're
supposed because like for me i'm like
i'm looking for a queen
for my
winterfell you know for my kingdom and
i'm like queen better learn how to carry
a chair
if [ __ ] happens you know so i'm like i
need a like a cersei lannister someone
that's like if you're gone i run this
[ __ ] too and i've had that even as small
as like in in high school
but i also knew then
to attract someone like that i need to
be
what this person would be attracted to
so i have to be complete because
complete
people aren't attracted to incomplete
people
you know damn you thought so deeply man
yeah i didn't think i was well i mean
one i didn't think it was a complete
incomplete type of thing
um for me it was just like i have
goals and aspirations and visions of who
i want to be as a person yeah
and the vision of myself was a very
capable
[ __ ] you attitude i'm gonna do it anyway
you know yeah
um so because i had that vision for
myself
i literally thought everyone else did
too
i was like you would
what do you mean you don't have that for
yourself like what do you mean you don't
want to be like a [ __ ] badass
what do you mean
yeah i mean i would just it just stops
there like you i mean you see it so i
don't know maybe i'm just take away more
at the time from
what everyone's looking at like even in
the movies right the star cheerleader
who does 10 000 backflips is gonna be
with the star quarterback
because he's equally athletic in his own
endeavors yeah so there's that mutual
like admiration
right like the the star volleyball
player
is most likely not going to be attracted
to the star couch potato
and more than and more so than taste
it's just even their lifestyles aren't
going to have them cross yeah you know
the the star volleyball player has more
often than not sharing the same court as
the basketball team so that's probably
why they're even in the same proxemics
as each other so she's probably gonna
date the star basketball player or
whatever you know so it's just that's
what i just started noticing i just
noticed at a young age
that um
like like attracts like
and not only that
uh in terms of like own personal
preference but just lifestyle attracts
lifestyle yeah right why are there so
many photographers that date models
because they're just rubbing shoulders
that way
it's just it's not like a you know
i wonder how that happened that's so
unusual it's like no they're [ __ ]
working together obviously yeah you know
so i just kind of just saw that at a
young age and i just realized okay cool
then if i want um damn you're a pattern
picker-upper yeah like if i want to find
more complete people
then i need to work myself up to the
upper echelon
of my own
industry or my own whatever endeavors to
find those complete people
i see
right yeah i mean even in the military
you see like that like there's literally
a code in the uniform services of
military justice
there's a code where there's like no
fraternization
so even like the enlisted technically
aren't should shouldn't be dating an
officer
you know there's just so i just started
to like oh yeah people mingle there's
certain places where people are supposed
to mingle and then they work together
and then those become your friends like
i i totally got it yeah
yeah
hmm yeah i i mean i guess i
i understood it i just didn't put it in
a pattern yet growing up right because
then
like when people were finding their
significant other in places that they
don't usually congregate at or that they
don't usually like so an example would
be like at a club
right and then
um that's not really part of their
lifestyle but they're going to a club to
find a possible
um relationship it's like
now you're val you're saying that that
those are the things that you value
right like if they're constantly
partying or drinking or whatever like
those are things that are coming back
into the relationship it says something
about their personality then why would
you go there if you really want someone
that's gonna be a little bit more
elevated or goal oriented or whatever um
then probably
i don't know look for them at school
when you're at school or look for them
like at a club like start joining
different clubs that like pertain to the
things
that you value in people which would be
like athleticism or like academics or
book club or whatever and like put
yourself in that situation because
that's or like in that club or in that
vicinity because that like like you said
like attracts like
because i've always been like wait why
would you
if you're looking for a [ __ ]
wifey type why would you go to a [ __ ]
strip club and try to find a wifey
like it can't work there are outliers
but it's [ __ ] difficult
yeah
yeah that's what i always thought too
i said i never really i was like okay
cool i understand if we're just gonna
drink with the boys
and like talk with chicks and flirt with
chicks but i knew i wasn't going to find
my wife there yeah you know or like it's
possible because i'm not saying like
it's possible to roll
it's very roll a 7 or 11 you know it's
hard but there's [ __ ] i don't know 10
built 20 other numbers that are going to
arrive first before you hit that so it
is possible but it's just the chances
aren't
likely you know and then when you get
there there's a lot of uh vetting that
has to happen yeah because now if you
found that same chick let's say you're
into god like crazy or like you're very
religious
and you find that same chick at church
the vetting is
like to get closer to her and and see if
she's the one
um then it's all of the a lot of that
has has gone away yeah like even i think
um when i was uh in pre-med
and um because i was in my colleges i
was still partying
and then so like i like i don't know
maybe this is unique to me but i like to
like hold uh
i like to think about things
hypothetically a lot like to run little
experiments in my mind
so i would always go like
what what's chances are more likely
to find a cute girl
in the pre-med program
or
to find a pre-med girl at the club
you know
so i'm like if i'm looking for like a
significant other that's like long-term
i'm like that's a waste of time because
there's i don't know 500 chicks here
the chances of finding one pre-med girl
i think it's gonna be really tough
but if i was probably studying because
she needs to be studying yeah but if i
go to the if i'm in my pre-med class
there might only be i don't know 50
chicks here
but the chances of one of them being
cute or that i'm attracted to is so much
higher and i don't have to cut through
so much noise i could just go okay cool
if i want to find someone with the same
occupation it's already here now i just
got to find someone that we hit it off
physically or spiritually or whatever um
and humor wise
and that always just made like way more
sense to me yeah same
yeah 100
um so then what would you say as someone
that is very peanut butter what would
you say is your ideal relationship then
or even love style
love stuff i think what we have right
now what do we have
and it better be [ __ ] you can't
say anything else this is a [ __ ] trap
question dude oh thank you for trying to
trap me um
so i like to see things like one of the
things that actually turned me on about
you
um is you know all the times where you
go to la with taika by yourself
that's hot
oh really yeah yeah and it's not even a
thing why is it so hot
um just cause like
it's like i think it's like
it's so i could so easily see both ways
girls going i'm not driving to l.a by
myself i can hear that
and i could hear the other way dudes
insecure dudes i'm not going to let my
lady drive to l.a by herself
because i tell him that makes me sense
weakness on both yeah you know yeah
cause i'm like okay so you're telling me
if your lady
was a like secret service or fbi agent
you wouldn't let her and she's more
capable than you you wouldn't let her
drive four hours by herself
that dude would probably oh well it's
because you could shoot to the fbi agent
i'm like yeah
then that just means your lady right now
is far
from being an fbi agent she's really far
from being complete
you know so she has a lot of things she
needs to work on
so that's
you know what i mean it's a yeah so
that's how that's how i see it right
yeah yeah so and um because of that
when like when we first started like
figuring out an arrangement going to la
or vegas or whatever and then like let's
say i have to go to la first so i have
to come back or whatever oh cool yeah
i'll pick up taika and i'll meet you
there
i'm like oh my god
oh my [ __ ] god so hot
because you know i'm like i'm like she's
a bad [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] that can just
that like um
the typical things in question aren't
even in question because i'm [ __ ]
capable you know like i'm capable of
number one i could drive this [ __ ]
car my [ __ ] dainty woman hands aren't
gonna fall off my shoulders
you know like i can't like i can if this
car breaks down i'll know how to find a
gas station i can get directions like
i'm not
incapable
you know what i mean yeah so like
because of that i'm like that's hot like
every time i see independence out of you
it's hot i'm like that's funny do you
think i'm [ __ ] hot all the goddamn
time 24 7. majority of the time
it's rare okay
at least every day you make me do
something
what like [ __ ] wash your own dishes
that's not hot
when we have the rule of whoever gets
out of the bed first makes the [ __ ]
bed it's not hot at all no i'm just
kidding though oh that's that's fair
yeah so stuff like that i really enjoy
because i think
um when there's two complete people like
our lifestyle when there's two complete
people
because the joint things can be taken
over by either or
it gives the individuals bandwidth to
skyrocket and grow yeah right yeah so
like when i consider going to
la
for a shoot or whatever
opportunity presents itself i'd go yes
because i know this side is taken care
of i know when i go talk to you i go hey
babe
yeah go ahead for sure i'm like oh but i
thought we were gonna meet there i'll
drive cool like it's like that right so
i just elevated my king status yeah
right versus someone asked me hey this
thing happened oh you know what i gotta
ask my wife
i gotta see if my wife gives me
permission
you know yeah and then i go hey babe i
gotta go to la to do whatever and then
they're like but who's gonna take me
i'm gonna
be like by myself that's so crazy i'm
gonna fly by myself or drive myself you
know then i'm like oh baby what about
that
and so it makes it like a
it makes
the ability to make king decisions
very drawn out slow down and then so
that's why i don't like that
codependency because it brings both
people
down you know versus when i'm complete
you're complete and we come together to
make things better i think we can both
grow harder and oh yeah
real hard you know
let's grow [ __ ] grow then we can we
can grow harder
and uh
and be more yeah you know so that's why
i really love our our love style yeah i
think it's pretty rad and then of course
it's like we're not
not everyone's like [ __ ] conqueror
like 24 7. so when it's cuny time in the
middle of the bed we're just both cuny
you know we're both under the blinkiest
mirror little cuny yeah we can't be
lopez food today yeah
yeah yeah no i love that no i love our
relationship i love i love where we're
at i love how far we've come
um i love it's it's such a unique
relationship it's one like i've never
had before
um
and like remember like i had just broken
up
uh i think i was like maybe a month or
two like single and i was still like
[ __ ] all mopey about it cause i'm
like
honestly i'm just like man
i'm gonna sound like you right now
but this is the most humble way i can
say it because i have so much self-love
where i'm like [ __ ] man i'm so down on
myself that i let this relationship take
the its toll on me like this
because i know i'm the [ __ ]
like [ __ ] man i shouldn't have i
shouldn't have been in it this long and
that's why i was mopey it wasn't like oh
this relationship ended it was more like
[ __ ] man i can't believe i allowed
myself to be in this situation and
that's the healthiest way to look at it
because if you're not a fan of yourself
who else can be a fan of you yeah true
you know yeah no one's going to be a fan
yeah i think it's got to be you're a fan
of yourself first not like have your own
head up your own ass yeah but you got to
be you got to love yourself be proud of
yourself
and then other people can love you
because
uh if i love you for what you're not
that's false love yeah you're getting
tricked yeah i need to love you for what
for what you love about yourself then we
match and we see eye to eye you know and
the same thing with me you love the
things about me that i love about myself
we're matched we see eye to eye and
that's how we have a really healthy
relationship if you love things that i
don't see in myself that's already a
huge uh insecurity and that's already a
rift in the
in the beginning well and that that's
another personality right yeah it's like
another person
um
yeah and i just remember being so down
about myself and going like [ __ ] man
like i know i'm [ __ ] dope like why
did i let this happen
um and i remember like you and i this is
our trip our snowboarding trip we were
just kind of like
i was just kind of like not giving you
my problems but you know i think you
felt like me being down and i think you
thought it was about um no you actually
you didn't you were actually listening
to what i was saying
and like the fact that we were able to
have such a
uh open vulnerable conversation
and it felt just like so elevated didn't
feel like anyone was talking [ __ ] about
anyone it didn't feel like
like it
the x wasn't even a thing you know like
the x wasn't even part of the
conversation it was more so like
like dang why how do you think this got
to here and how do you think you handled
that or how do you think you know
it was like very deep questions and i'm
like i remember telling you like
man bart like
you give me hope
you give me hope that one day i'm gonna
like if you exist because you were such
a homie in my eyes that i was like if
you exist i know that there's people
like you out there like i'm not i was
never thinking like i'm going to be with
you yeah but i like your type of person
but you're already in my homie bucket
like you're already in my homey
circle so like there's no chance of
romantic anything but i'm like man
you're tight dude
if you're if there's if you exist
there's got to be other people like you
and lo and behold
i remember when he said that too here we
are you're in my homie bucky too yeah so
i was like yup there's plenty of me out
there
it must have been like you know like the
dumb and dumber moment but the bus pulls
up would you guys happen to know who
could rub lotion all over our bodies
well you're in luck because if you go
that way
there's a town full of people
and then and then they go
oh do you know what we just did we're so
stupid wait
wait
the bus stops he's so dumb
the town's that way
that's for sure us man
so like um i do believe in the languages
absolutely
but
to a certain extent i feel like we all
possess all of it
um and we all need to have a little bit
of these things these buckets filled
even though you're gonna disagree i feel
like maybe it's just from my own
perspective here
i feel like a lot of little like things
getting filled up is is good
mine really is just one thing what is it
quality time
really that's it what are the other ones
so there's uh acts of service oh at
quality time active services too you
just you were so
[ __ ]
convinced
you're like nope that's it that's it if
i wouldn't have [ __ ] asked more
questions
you son of a [ __ ] fine those two
none of the other ones no keep keep
going so there's words of affirmation
quality time
access to service gift uh yeah gifts and
then physical touch
and
isn't there like two more i forgot there
could be more
i think there's seven there's seven of
them i think so
yeah but those are the only two that i
really care about
let me see
i gotta look it up okay
i can't believe you man
let's see what are they uh physical
touch communication
oh wait did i is there seven i just made
that up let me just put love languages
what are they
oh they're five sorry i guess that is
five we got five right mm-hmm okay so
you're not physical touch no i mean it's
nice but i don't it doesn't uh fill me
up
but so if we were to remove that
completely
yeah if we paint the extremes no no what
what what what fills me up so much so
i'm painting the extremes right 100 of
this zero of this
quality time let's say everything i like
to do you do with me we go shooting we
go scuba diving
we go scuba d no that's
if we go uh
scuba diving we go
shooting we go off-roading go camping do
all the things that i like to do that
would fill me up so much that i wouldn't
even need you to touch me
wow yeah
obviously we're still having sex
how
because visual to touch is like like oh
you don't think your dick physically
touches my [ __ ] badge spiritually it
does
[Laughter]
okay dude
[Laughter]
well then okay then maybe it's just me
but yeah i feel like i
[ __ ] did i just [ __ ] say what you
just said in the beginning
that and then acts of service yeah so
when i come home right and then you make
such a huge effort to make the house
clean and all that stuff like i feel
filled with love too oh my gosh she
cared about me so much as she did all
this that's so cute that you think i did
it for you
because you know me like my my mental
space has so much [ __ ] going on that if
my physical space has so much [ __ ] going
on
i'm like holy [ __ ] i can't i can't
function in this space so i literally do
it for myself
and you just so happen to benefit and i
know that it makes you comfortable too
but the bigger one is me yeah then
that's a that's a double whammy
helps out it's cutie my little peanut
butter yeah
well then damn okay
then uh yeah i do need a little bit of
the other ones but if i had to say my
biggest one
i think i'm between words of affirmation
and um
an acts of service what look because i'm
looking at the chart and all of them are
maxed out
i don't give a [ __ ] about gifts i got
two gifts you don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] about gifts
um what are the ones physical touch i
don't really care about that either no
you don't care about them you see
so that's already two gone what are the
other what's the other one uh words of
affirmation for sure that's me acts of
service service quality time i don't
give a [ __ ] about quality time you don't
care if i'm around you because every
time i'm gone you'll miss me so much is
that quality time yeah
all right fine then i'm three three out
of five that's not bad yeah like if i if
i lived the stand-up comedian schedule
you wouldn't like that
i wouldn't like that i think i would it
would kill me yeah that's that's uh
that's i'd be like all right i guess i'm
gonna be working remotely now i'm gonna
be on your schedule so for sure quality
time because if i'm gone every single
weekend for every single year yeah i'm
gonna be with you like tom saying he
checked into 400 hotels a year yeah
guess what i'm so so have i [ __ ]
that's crazy yeah so quality time for
sure yeah so have i
am my words of affirmation that heavy oh
yeah am i yeah all right well then [ __ ]
i'm words of affirmation
acts of service
i think okay well then yeah i'm that too
let's see
out of the five at least three bars are
like
okay well then [ __ ] i eat my words
there we go
well then down
i learned a lot though
thank you you're welcome all right my
little peanut butter it's [ __ ] cute a
big kidney all right well on that note
if you've made it this far i hope you
haven't puked too much from all this
[ __ ] cuteness
but man we just we can't we can't hold
it in we [ __ ] love each other and
we're partners for life and no matter
how dumb you look with those headphones
i still think you're the sexiest person
ever thank you
all right cutie pie and you two cutie
pies listening uh love you guys as well
and i hope you got some some good little
inside and gems from this that you can
take away and add to all of your
relationships
but until next time
we'll talk soon see you guys soon bye